foreign
hi welcome back sounds like you had a
great morning
um I hope you enjoyed everything last
night I had a great time at the alumni
reception I know you all had talk
afterwards so I hope all of this has um
been a really nice experience for you we
still have a couple of more sessions
today and I know this will probably be
one of the
um of utmost interest to all of you so
without further Ado I'd like to kick off
your GSB career Journey with our
assistant Dean and director Jamie shine
of our career Management Center me
hi everyone it's great to see you all
here it's great to have folks on Zoom as
well I will be um I'm thrilled to
welcome you on behalf of the career
Management Center on all of our team
there and I will be talking for a few
minutes to give you a sense of what it's
like
um from a career's perspective at the
GSB and then I'll welcome up our panel
of current students and so you you
notice that um we say that your career
Journey really starts with you and we
say that because when you're here our
goal in working with you is to ensure
that as you go through the process and
as you end up with a job or an
internship that you really feel grounded
in an understanding of your personal
values priorities skills and interests
we hope that you're satisfied that
you've considered all different opportun
possibilities we hope that you're
confident in your preparation and we
hope you're excited about the
opportunity that you're going to pursue
now when we talk about a career Journey
it sounds very structured and and like
it's a clear process but we also know
that when you're here at the GSB it can
feel more like this there are tons of
competing priorities there are tons of
competing events and it's really hard to
stay focused on what's important to you
and so part of the work we do is to help
you really identify what is important to
you and to put some structure around
what may feel a little chaotic and we do
that by
um what we call by implementing what we
call the career Journey framework it's
something that we developed after years
of working with students like you and it
starts with you it starts with
reflecting on what is important to you
what your values are what your
priorities are and those can really help
you focus as you explore different
Industries different opportunities and
then Target companies and then
ultimately after you interview you get
some offers you decide what you want to
do that's where the the framework comes
together because we hope that you will
then reflect back on those values and
priorities that you identified early on
and ensure that the opportunity you
accept is going to map to those values
and priorities
so as we work with students and we we do
this every year we ask students the um
to tell us what companies they're
interested in this is what the class of
2024 told us and we'll ask you the same
this summer now this list is very long
it's actually shorter than the class
before so these guys listed about over
400 companies that they were potentially
interested in joining for an internship
or a job but there are a couple things
that are consistent from year to year
the list is long and many of the
companies most of the companies are only
mentioned by one student and that really
is a reflection of the breadth of your
interests the breadth of your goals and
we're here to support you in that we're
set up so that we can support you as you
explore your very own personal career
opportunities the other thing that's
consistent here is the most common
response now the most common response
every year is this one it's unknown
and there's a couple reasons for that
number one I'm sure you've heard this
before the GSB is a transformational
opportunity you're coming here for a new
experience and you may be here to
explore a new idea A New Path you may be
here to Pivot from from a to a different
function to a different industry and so
you may not know yet where that's going
to lead you and you're going to take the
two years here to explore that that's
great we're here to support you now some
of you are also maybe here to start your
own company
and we work very closely with the center
for entrepreneurial studies and we
students go back and forth between us
all the time I'm going to focus on job
Seekers today but we know that um you it
may be unknown because you don't know
what company you're going to start and
that's all great we have tons of
resources here to support you
and the resources are come in a bunch of
different flavors one we have a
curriculum of Career Education we have
workshops we have employer presentations
and our Career Education all everything
related to career at the GSB is opt-in
you can participate in as many of the
workshops visit as many of the employers
as you wish that are relevant to you we
also have a team of six full-time career
advisors they have different industry
focuses and you can meet with one you
can meet with all you can it can vary
depending on where you are you might
want to meet with one for interview prep
and someone else when you're negotiating
an offer that's fine that's the way
we're set up
we also have an employer engagement team
so that list of companies helps to
inform the work of our employer
engagement team so they'll do Outreach
on your behalf they're talking to
companies all the time they are also
focused on Industries so they're keeping
up on the trends in different Industries
they are looking at companies that are
started companies that are getting
funded they keep track of the different
job boards they work with our alumni a
ton because of alumni are a great source
of job opportunities and they're here
for you they're kind of more behind the
scenes but they're here working for you
and then finally we have some fantastic
online resources really in-depth online
resources you'll see some of them now in
on mygsb and more will become available
to you when you're a student here so
take a look we encourage you to look at
the career experience tab on my GSB and
you'll see a whole bunch of great
resources there I'll mention a few
all right so what's next for for the CMC
when will you when will you next
interact with us well we have a couple
of workshops this summer one is called
creating your career possibilities and
that's an opportunity for you to think
about the um think about different
career options you might want to explore
and we really encourage at this point
expansive thinking we don't want you to
be too narrow to to think have the the
bar be too low we're going to think
expansively so this is a great Workshop
it's virtual and with your classmates
all around the world and then the next
is more tactical it's um an intern it'll
give you a sense of your MBA one year
the timeline of internship recruiting so
that's coming as well and then here's
here's um the resources on mygsb the
career in life reflection workbook is a
series of exercises you can do on your
own or maybe with a partner and we've
got career guides around different
Industries we've got the employment
report we just published it earlier this
month for the class of 2022 and then we
have really tactile things about putting
your resume and personal statement
together
so that's it for for me and without
further Ado let's bring up the panel
all right so um we have all of the the
panels information so we have oyenda we
have Preston Paula Kathleen and Jonathan
and all of their personal information is
up there so they can just go straight
into their career experiences
um and so what I'd love to do and we'll
just go straight down the line starting
with oyenda we'd love to have you kick
off by sharing a little bit about
yourself and your career aspirations
when you came to the GSB
okay hi everyone it's nice to see you
all
um my name is ayinda I prior to the USB
I walked in Consulting then at a startup
and coming into the gsv I knew I wanted
to stay in an entrepreneurial
um career so I explored three parts I
was thinking about either VC another
startup or the search fund and while I
was at the GSB while exploring search
funds I came across across PE Ops and so
after graduation I'll be working in
peops
hi I'm Preston coming into GSP I really
didn't know what I wanted to explore I
was debating going back into my previous
private Equity role I was interested in
exploring other investing roles such as
venture capital and public Equity
investing and I even had a small itch
for entrepreneurship
once I got here I was able to talk to
various alumni and go to Career events
to be able to demystify these various
career paths and I ended up deciding to
go into public Equity investing
good morning everyone excited to be here
with you this morning I'm Paula coming
to the GSP I wanted to Pivot both
company size because I was working for
early stage startups and Industry I was
working in fintech and wanted to move
into education uh because I had two
pivots I created multiple opportunities
to go and try out this different
hypotheses so on the education side I
joined the impact Fund in the Education
team to feel what investing in education
would be like and I did a g mix also in
an education company in Colombia to try
out the company size hypothesis uh I did
my summer at Google so I stick to the
same role product but in a larger
company this time uh finally I decided
to go back to Google and accept my offer
so enjoyed my summer opportunity very
much
good morning everyone welcome to the GSB
my name is Kathleen schwind uh prior to
the GSB I was working as an independent
consultant mainly with the federal
government and for organizations in the
Middle East you'll see the two plus up
there because I started that gig when I
was in undergrad to just continued it
through after my Master's until I came
to the business school so I knew that
coming into the GSB my long-term goal
was to serve in government so serve in
an appointed position in the white house
or the state department working on
National Security and defense topics and
so coming here I thought okay what is
the best Avenue through the private
sector to get to that role and so worked
very closely with the CMC landed with on
Consulting and so I worked at McKinsey
over the summer in their DC office with
public sector clients and we'll be going
back after that before pivoting again
back into the public sector
awesome all right hey everybody how's it
going I'm John so prior to the GSB I
worked at Vans the footwear company for
about four years
and I really didn't know whether I want
to keep working in what was kind of a
niche what was kind of like consumer
Footwear apparel is what I want to keep
doing I was thinking about moving to a
job at J crew and I decided I needed to
pause and that was a main reason I went
to business school was explored do I
want to keep working in this industry or
do I want to Pivot into something like
sports or entertainers so I wasn't even
thinking about and so what was nice was
talking to different CMC advisors going
to events talking to classmates very
quickly realized that yes I really do
like Footwear apparel I like the
creativity I like the brand part of it
but decided I want to explore different
areas Beyond just the corporate world
that I knew really well so that allowed
me to start thinking about startups as
an internship going into PVC all those
different areas and so I ended up
getting a startup internship for the
summer and pretty confident I wanted to
stay within the consumer space going
forward
great well John let's stick with you if
you think about your internship how did
you prepare and how did you ultimately
make the decision to accept that
internship sure so I'll be honest with
everybody I took I did not do really
very much on internship my first quarter
at GSB like my first priority when I got
here was really just to work on me think
about like mental physical health be
present meet up a bunch of people which
I think in the end was really beneficial
because when I started the actual
internship search process in January
February time I was a lot more confident
myself I had a lot more energy to
actually spend into it so the first
things that I did after working with the
CMC folks and later say all right I want
to stay in consumer because I did some
more investing interviews around PVC and
I realized quickly that I was just not
actually motivated to prep for the
interview so I could get half the way
but I wasn't that excited about it and I
was like I gotta take that as a signal
like this is just not something I'm that
interested in so that clarified myself I
was like I really want to focus on
Startup so I was able to Source them
through the CMC got an offer there but I
was also able to Source an opportunity
through a classmate basically a class
mate's boyfriend had started a
three-person or so startup and ended up
working with him for March April time
and decided like I really like this I'm
gonna be able to see a bunch of
different things I otherwise wouldn't be
able to be able to learn and so I ended
up doing that for the summer time
great great Kathleen
so my process was a bit more structured
just because of the nature of recruiting
for Consulting so again coming in with
this long-term goal my first step was to
go to the CMC I had hypothesis that I'd
be going into consulting or VC but
wanted to learn more about the
opportunities in both of them again with
this ultimate idea of pipping back into
the public sector so I went to the CMC
sat down with the advisors for
Consulting in VC decided that just by
the nature of timeline BC is usually a
little bit more self-sourcing that
starts in the winter and the spring
Consulting starts right after academic
adjustment period so AAP is if you
haven't heard of it it's the first five
weeks that you're at the GSB employers
can't reach out you're not looking for a
job it's a time to settle in get to know
your classmates really understand kind
of like John was saying what's important
to you what are you trying to get out of
this place in business school so right
after that ended Consulting interview
prep started Case Prep I'm talking with
classmates talking with recruiters that
came to campus and then those interviews
were early January ended up getting an
offer spoiler alert um and so by the end
of January I already had my offer in
hand after talking with a lot of
Partners at the firm and also with
classmates and the CMC to me it seemed
like the best opportunity to go forward
to both build a personal brand to build
an area of expertise to build up a
network that would help me get into the
White House or the state department and
so VC just became not relevant anymore
so Stefan McKenzie and was really glad I
did
uh on my own because I wanted to move to
later stage companies I decided to focus
on big Tech which follows a different
timeline so I started applying and
interviewing a little earlier than my
colleagues so as the first quarter
started I drew a strategy of the things
I want to focus on and the things I do
not want to try out like as you start
the quarter after AAP you're gonna see
there are multiple opportunities uh and
it can be kind of hard if you don't
decide the things that you do not want
to do I didn't want to spread myself to
Finn so I I just decided I don't want to
do VC I don't want to do be Ops I really
want to focus either big tech and and or
education posterior C
uh I applied by December I did all my
interviews uh in early January and got
offers by February
I think also like I Echo everything that
Kathleen and and Jonathan said one thing
which is also very important is to focus
energy and find resources when the time
comes to decide which offer to take uh
just like which one are you gonna able
to build a network or where you're going
to leverage your streams or the things
you want to test out uh so I did spend
quite some time and talked a lot to the
CMC advisors around which offer was best
suited to the things I wanted to pursue
and to me was also important to have uh
two different experiences close to each
other so I made sure that I chose a
company that was very different from
Google in my GMX just to say like where
do I feel more energized like where do I
feel like I have the best fit uh so just
like also besides the CMC there are a
lot of clubs that you can reach out to
like to talk to people to alumni to
current students to kind of like hear
the unfiltered version of their
experiences so that was very important
to me going through all of these
informal conversations
for me I first had to decide what I want
to do for my summer internship I went to
a CMC event called Career and life
priorities then prior to this event was
we created three potential career paths
we could pursue for me one of these
career paths required that I interned in
the field and that was public Equity
investing and the other two career paths
I'd be able to explore as MBA 2 and that
was entrepreneurship and potentially
going back to my previous private Equity
Firm
so once I narrowed it down to public
Equity investing I went to the CMC to
create a list of high priority firms to
reach out to we came up about five firms
largely mutual funds and then they
connected me with alumni at all those
firms so I could start conversations
with them
on the interview prep front the main
deliverable you have to do is a stock
pitch so I leverage resources from the
finance and investment Club here to
create that stock pitch I then practiced
it with MBA 2s the CMC as well as
communication coaches which are like our
amazing resource we all get access to as
a student here
finally before all my real interviews I
did a kind of more holistic interview
um prep session with the CMC
specifically Bill Thompson who actually
used to be a senior vice president at
Fidelity the place I ended up going to
I got my offer from Fidelity early on
kind of before the first quarter ended
which is
um typically early for the processes
they run and I really like the firms
that decided to accept it
um on my end like I said earlier I came
in with three options so that was VC
join another startup or do search funds
and so just do my own thing
um very early on in the quarter I sat
with the CMC to discuss what a career
MVC would look like and they suggested
that I speak to people in the industry
they connected me to people in the
industry after a lot of those
conversations I didn't feel very excited
about going into VC and so I in a
follow-on conversation with the CMC we
decided to rule out VC as an option and
so I moved on to my next option which
was startups and considering I had
worked in startups before
um a question that came up in my
conversation with one of the cmca
advisors was what gets you excited what
are you most excited about and that for
me was luxury fashion just because I
enjoyed it um as a hobby or just on the
side and so I decided to join or try to
look for opportunities we think that
that space for the summer to explore
whether or not I wanted to stay in that
space in pivot Industries
in terms of timeline first quarter was
exploring VC and ruling that out second
quarter was a lot of introspection
thinking about what matters most to me
what do I enjoy what gives me energy and
then the third quarter was then looking
for opportunities within that space and
because startup recruiting starts pretty
late in the year I think I got my offer
like four weeks before school went out
so from the first interaction to when I
got the offer it was like five days but
then that was like right before school
went out so sometimes there could be
that anxiety around everyone has an
offer but you don't but then you just
have to understand the industries that
you're interacting with and what their
timelines typically look like right
thanks agenda a couple things I want to
highlight that you heard from them one
is a lot of reflection going on which is
definitely something we emphasize and
the the workshop that Preston described
as the workshop that we're going to be
offering over the summer the second
thing you heard was ruling things out
definitely important to to you know get
the noise away and then the third was
the very different timelines they had
for their recruiting and their offers
and their acceptances so that's really
typical people are getting offers
throughout the year from early on to you
know even even less than four weeks
before school is out so that's great all
right thank you so um again we'll stick
with you and can you tell us about how
your internship informed your post GSB
plans and also both
ayinda and Paula are international
students and so if you could also just
touch on um what that was like in and
how you Incorporated that into your job
search thinking
okay so after the summer at this Tech
startup
um I liked the job but it very much felt
like what I was doing before the GSP it
was a different industry but my function
was the same and one of the things that
I thought about coming to the GSB was to
push myself a little harder take more
risk so coming back from the summer I
then ruled out like joining an early
stage startup as an option because I
felt like I had done that and for me the
growth that I wanted out of the GSB was
to be able to take on the full
responsibility of an organization and
run it so I focused now on the search
fund and it was while exploring what
like a career and search fund looks like
that I came across PE Ops because there
was a similar opportunity
um in that in that organization
um so yeah that was helpful to help me
understand like what I enjoyed what what
I could do and what I could do more of
as an international student I really
wasn't concerned about the summer
because every international student gets
the CPT which allows you to work over
the summer and doesn't require the
organization to do anything from a
full-time perspective it didn't really
apply to me because the company I ended
up accepting an offer from
um sponsors International students
however I have spoken to a lot of
international students who are concerned
about like companies sponsoring them or
not and I think that's something a
conversation you should have very early
on with the organization to understand
whether or not you're going to sponsor
you and whether or not that's a decision
that's fine with you and then there are
some companies who don't understand the
sponsorship process and think it's one
big complicated mystery and that's an
opportunity for you to have that
conversation with them and demystify and
highlight the steps they need to take in
order to sponsor you and I have seen
cases where people have done that and
companies that have never sponsored an
international student end up sponsoring
them
for me I really viewed the role of a
summer internship as a way to trial run
a different career path I ended up
loving my time at Fidelity I loved how
it was a really pure form of investing
and as I kind of made the As I did like
a pro con listing about compensation
lifestyle autonomy and job itself first
private Equity I thought Fidelity would
be a better fit for for me personally
and decide to go back there full time
um for me similarly joinda I felt
extremely comfortable in my g mix
because I was doing product Charlie
stage that's the thing I wanted to do
and not that comfortable within Google
so I felt like that's the place I had
the most to learn from were a very
different skill set uh was required from
from my end that's why I decided to
accept Google's offer uh being an
international student there were also
other factors uh come into play for my
decision so I wanted a company that
would sponsor my Visa beyond the CPT a
zoinda mentioned I wanted a company that
had a lot of international Mobility what
if I want to transfer to Brazil a few
years from now maybe I want to stay at
the same company so I also wanted to
have that visibility
I used a lot of the online resources at
the CMC website there are like some
databases where International students
are working at right now where they work
right out of the GSB uh so I had a lot
of conversations with International
students uh at Google at that moment
just to hear how has it been for them uh
and I think also rely on the clubs a lot
in my case I relied on lhasa the Latin
America Student Association club uh just
like to discuss with other students how
they were going around their own
decisions like alumni from the club uh
when when it was their turn to choose
how they went about it I think that's
important to collect this multiple
perspectives before committing to
something uh and the last thing I wanted
to say is like there are other things
beyond your formal internship to try out
these hypotheses you have so in my case
I did the impact fun and that informed
me somehow of the decision moving
forward
for me I always had an idea that a
Consulting would work out really well
just the way that I learned the like the
way I like to work on projects and I had
a great summer not only because I was
staffed in the Bahamas so spending 45
days a week down there
um but really going in what helped me
decide was coming up with three things
that I wanted to test out and see if
Mckenzie was the right place uh one of
those was building an area of expertise
um can I you know after a couple of
years there walk away with a one or two
cent explanation of what am I an expert
at and why would someone want to put me
in their Administration number two was a
network like how do you you know with
politics with a lot of things it's all
about who you know and so is Mackenzie a
place that is going to make that Network
for me specifically in the National
Security and defense space and the third
thing was Finding champions in in
mentors which I think is important
across Industries but especially in a
space that it is very much you know
seniority based there's a lot of changes
happening if I can find those people who
will help invest in my career that was
essential and McKenzie blew it out of
the the park in all three
that's awesome all right so when you get
to Stanford you hear a stat about how
like 90 of startups fail and if you're
like me you're like that doesn't apply
to me or like anything that I would
touch it turns out it did I mean so over
the summer I worked for a startup that
didn't fail but definitely struggled and
that was an incredible learning
experience for me you know as I said it
was really small so I got to touch
everything from visiting factories
seeing lawyers
um making a pitch deck doing sales tax
all the stuff that I really wanted
responsibility for but I also got to see
the struggles that come with like a
really small startup at the beginning
and that was all learning for me like my
risk profile isn't necessarily for that
and that's okay but it also confirmed
like I do love responsibility especially
responsibility that related to Brands
consumer Footwear apparel so I was like
great I know where I want to go I can
cross off a really early stage startup I
can clarify the fact that my end goal
five to ten years from now is to be the
president of a brand so what what steps
do I need to go to actually achieve that
so as you can tell I am the only person
here right now on this panel that
doesn't have a job going forward but
that's okay I feel good about like the
recruiting cycle hasn't necessarily
started for me just yet just like
internship Cycles come different times
but I know that I want to find something
that's a little bit more mature than the
startup that I worked at previously but
keep that level of responsibility and be
able to to grow along the way
fantastic thanks John let's stick with
you and and we have time for a lightning
round great
um so if you could share with uh the our
audience um what you know now about the
CMC or the job search process that you
wish you had known when you were sitting
well on sitting on zoom in most of your
cases right yeah so you you actually had
it on one of your slides earlier so
maybe you had told me during my admin
weekend I didn't pay attention to it but
the uh the idea of talking to multiple
uh members of the CMC so the main person
I talk to is this lovely woman named
Grace who really knows consumer really
well and I think I would have thought
like I'll just be with her that'll be
fine but I also met with Bill Thompson
that I think Preston mentioned I
mentioned met with other people at the
CMC and they were all really powerful
and giving me more perspectives able to
help in different sorts of ways and to
be honest they all kind of feel like
therapy sessions when you talk to them
so that in itself was nice just to hear
from a bunch of different folks
thanks for me there are more resources
at the GSB that you can possibly take
advantage of whether that's the CMC and
having so many advisors for Consulting
so many opportunities for Case Prep but
not only the CMC but faculty and your
classmates as well I mean you could walk
around and be getting coffee with
someone and find out that they're
working exactly for the partner that you
want to get connected with so for me
that was
um it wasn't surprising but just like
the breadth and the depth of resources
uh was definitely mind-blowing
uh for me coming to the GSB I thought I
needed to have very structured questions
before scheduling a session with a CMC
advisor so I made the mistake of
scheduling my first advice session after
I got my first offer and I wish I had to
use these advisors to kind of outline my
strategy before moving forward I thought
like I'm not ready for the session but
that's what they're there for uh and if
I can give a second advice for
international students they call the
workshops especially those related to
networking I felt those were very
helpful to me
for me I had no idea how incredible the
professional backgrounds were of the CMC
advisors a lot of like I mentioned like
Bill Thompson Senior vice president
Fidelity and that's like pretty typical
amongst all of them they've all done
these incredible careers and they've
worked on a lot of either Industries or
functions that you're interested in so
reach out like as early as possible to
them to talk about your hypothesis what
you might be interested in and they can
give you a ton of valuable advice so so
don't wait until you're more further
along in the process just do it when you
get here when you just want to think
about something out loud
yeah I'm gonna also Echo everything
around meeting with the CMC advisors but
I think one other thing I didn't really
think would happen coming to jsb was
that I would get my internship and my
full-time through CMC related events or
directly from CMC I just thought I was
going to be Superwoman and figure it out
by myself but my internship was
literally on the CMC job portal
um and I was checking that every day
because I clearly didn't have a job like
a month before the summer I wrote
Breakfast I was like okay I need to find
something I'm checking the CMC every day
and I see this very perfect opportunity
and I'm like wow okay this is surprising
and then my full-time offer
um Alpine had a CMC
event where they came to speak to the
students and I had a gap between my two
classes and I'm like okay there's a CMC
event I'm just going to roll through to
that and then I'm sitting there
listening to what they do and I'm like
oh my God this sounds exactly like what
I wanted to do and so I ended up
applying to that and getting the job but
I would never guess that that would be
how I would find my jobs
great thank you
all right we we have some time for
questions from you all so um Christine
do we have a microphone or should I just
repeat the questions
okay
[Music]
okay great uh any questions for the
panel
but it also sounds like a lot of
recruiting starts pretty early in the
first quarter so do you have to be like
ready since that academic condition
period ends I'll take that one and then
I'll hand it off to any of the panelists
so during the academic adjustment period
I would say if from when I hear from
students it's really busy and then the
academic adjustment period ends and then
it's really really busy
um but the idea is that I think John
mentioned that it's where you kind of
get grounded in you know your life being
a student again but there's also a ton
of the Career Education workshops that I
mentioned a lot of them happen in the
Autumn quarter during the AAP so
um things like
um the you know whether it's a
networking Workshop we have a day that's
called Career exploration day where we
bring eight panels of alumni back that
perform that are working in jobs that
are you know closely aligned to what a
lot of students that seem to be
interested in so there's still a lot you
can do to help clarify fi where you want
to focus and then there's some there are
some recruiting who recruited in the
fall
yeah so there's there's some recruiting
in the fall
um but about
um a lot of students get their jobs in
the late winter or spring so this is
super typical
um where you know you might right now if
you think about it it's a small Growth
Company they don't really have the
runway They Don't Really they don't have
uh planning so far in advance that they
know what internships they're going to
offer for the spring so they'll you know
they'll get their plans in line round
about now between now and April and then
they'll start to recruit so does anyone
want to chime in on AAP and what you
need to do after yeah I'll just add one
quick thing
um I don't know what people's undergrad
experiences were like but it felt like
they were a very few small number of
jobs that everyone was competing for and
it could feel competitive whereas I feel
like at the GSB everyone's doing their
very own individualized career path that
people know what they want and I think
from that that naturally spews like a
big Vibe of collaboration so while AAP
might end and then people some people
are going to go into the job search
right away not everyone is doing it and
you don't feel that same sense of like
oh I got to be keeping up I got to be
doing this sort of thing that I think
was a lot more common in undergrad
experience
and I'll just add so I recruited in the
fall but Fidelity has a more formal
recruiting process for Stanford in the
winter after the AAP period as also an
MLT and they had Fidelity had a
recruiting process with MLT and that's
why I had earlier interviews because I
went through that route for my
recruiting
and MLT is management leaders for
tomorrow
great thank you any other questions
I don't see
oh hi
great so the question is
um how plugged in Stanford is to
startups outside the Bay Area New York
and Boston were the examples does anyone
want to chime in here
I can go again I don't want to dominate
but I so to that point the I did get an
offer for a New York apparel startup
that was sourced through the CMC and I
actually maintained a relationship with
them and I've been talking with them
about a full-time role so I think there
are definite sources of it and just I
feel like anecdotally a lot of people
from Stanford Stu also go to New York so
there's still the network there I think
the Bay Area just might be bigger from
it just it's right there right we're
like 10 20 miles away so I think that's
the difference but I don't feel like it
was only
um only Bay Area
yeah and in my case
um the company had offices in the Bay
and New York so I was in the Bay area
for a little bit because that was very
kind of like the product and the
technical side was and then I was in the
New York side as well because that was
where the fashion and the photo shoots
happened so
um I got I worked I worked remotely
technically but um I think it's not very
like there are opportunities wherever
you're interested in and it's not just
specific to the Bay
yeah and we do do Outreach around the
well around the world
um we I was in New York this summer and
there's just amazing set of alumni who
are in the healthcare space and startup
space certainly in finance we go down to
La arts media entertainment a lot of
companies down there and so we'll we'll
reach out um zoom's actually been great
for that we do a lot of our Outreach on
Zoom now nothing nothing beats in person
for really feeling what a company is
like but we um we maintain relationships
with companies all around the world and
interestingly
um because of the GSB is a as a stem
degree so our International students can
stay for up to three years
using opt and so a lot of our
International students have stayed in
the U.S but we certainly also support
people doing International Job searches
yes Christine
all right so the question is did anyone
do a pre-mba internship and then and
then I can chime in on the access before
for our admins
um I did I did a plan B internship in VC
again I had three cars I was exploring
and so that helped me inform but
ironically I did get that internship
through my Stanford class so we were on
slack and people were just posting
opportunities and I reached out to one
of my classmates that I hadn't met
before and I was like hey you posted
this
um can you make a connection as you did
and I thought it was a good use of my
time but I also know a lot of people who
haven't so
I also did a pre-mba internship and I
actually sourced that with a current GSB
student that I met during admit weekend
uh and I ended up interning at the
company she did her summer internship
and uh I was interested in education she
was also I'm a joint degree student with
the education school and this student
was also doing the joint degree program
so she connected me to a few companies
and I decided to join one for a
three-month uh pre-mba internship
yeah in terms of access to the CMC
and the pre-mba internships we will post
some pre-mba internships but many of
them are informal so um take a look on
my GSB and the career experiences page
and you'll find the ones that that we
know about but I would say it's much
more common to go the way that oyenda
and Paula did where um you're sourcing
it on your own we also
um have very limited
um very limited resources for admitted
students before school starts so we do
the series of workshops and there are
some opportunities to interact with our
advisors but most of that kicks off
it'll kick off in week zero which is you
know your first week here we have a a
great session called engaging with the
CMC different than when you guys are
here
um
um and you have a chance to meet
everyone in the in the career Management
Center all of the advisors everyone in
employer Outreach we have the center for
entrepreneurial studies for social
Innovation so all of the adjacent groups
you'll have a chance to meet them right
when you get here
yes all right and so that brings us to
the end of our time thank you very much
to our panels
[Music]